a CNN panel of Democrat voters confirms
my 2020 predictions the party is moving
left of Lenin forget moderation forget
focusing on the economy in 2020 it's the
Sun monsters stupid then liz warren
continues to botch identity politics
masturbation becomes a sexual
orientation and Christians around the
world gorged themselves as Mardi Gras
leads us into Lent
I'm Michael Nolan this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
Lansdale a bunch of Brule happy Mardi
Gras you are very very lucky that none
of the producers has any beads on him
today because otherwise you'd be getting
this show let me tell you quite a lot to
get to I have been vindicated in my 2020
predictions by no less an expert than
CNN we'll get to it in a second but
first let's make a little money honey
with Boleyn branch Boleyn branch is the
perfect copy if you already got a good
mattress you want to make sure you got a
good mattress - Boleyn branch sheets are
the perfect complement and actually back
when I had a bad mattress the one thing
that made it nice was my Bolin bran
sheets getting a great night's sleep is
easier and more affordable than you
think you don't need a new expensive
mattress you don't need sleeping pills
you don't need all of those things the
way to get a good night's sleep on the
cheap is a Boleyn branch everything
Boleyn branch makes from bedding to
blankets is made from 100% pure organic
cotton which means they start out super
soft and they get softer over time how
can you get very high-end luxury sheets
for a fraction of the cost Boleyn branch
because Boleyn branch cuts out the
middleman you'd be spending $1,000 in
the store maybe here they're only a
couple hundred bucks everyone who tries
Boleyn branch sheets loves them that's
why they have thousands of five-star
reviews
Forbes Wall Street Journal Fast Company
are all talking about bolt and branch
even three u.s. presidents sleep on
Boland branch sheets shipping is free
you can try them for 30 nights if you
don't love them send them back for a
refund but you're not gonna want to send
them back get started right now my
listeners get $50 off your first set of
sheets this is a great deal you should
go right now to Boland branch com promo
code Michael mi CH AE L you will not
regret it Boleyn branch comm for $50 off
your first set of sheets Bo LL and
branch comm promo code Michael mi CH AE
elbow and branch comm promo code Michael
study after study shows that little ol
me
is correct about 2020 the consensus view
about 2020 that we have been hearing now
for a while is the Democrats are they're
gonna want a moderate they're gonna want
a centrist they're gonna look look if
they run Joe Biden they'll be great the
consensus view it's the economy stupid
that's what they would always say James
Carville
this famously for Bill Clinton's runs so
you know Democrats if they just focus on
practical issues working families that's
the way that they're gonna win in 2020
and the thing is the consensus view is
always wrong the Democrats are not going
to go for that maybe that would work if
they could do it but the Democrats are
simply not going to go for it my view on
this is that the Democrats are out for
blood they are triggered on an hourly
basis by Donald Trump they pay attention
to those tweets with more attention than
they give to their families or to their
jobs they are obsessed with it they're
obsessed with him they want to punch
back they are basically as infuriated by
him as as right-wingers were by Barack
Obama and now they are learning a lesson
that we have previously learned the old
view the 90s view is that it's the
economy stupid it would basically be the
neoliberal view stop arguing about the
culture wars stop worrying
arguing about religion just focus on
material things that's what people
really care about at the end of the day
that's all they want to vote on it's
just if they're getting a little bit
more money or a little less money that's
all that it is it's not the 90s anymore
and there is actually a reaction in both
political parties right now against what
we would call neoliberalism against this
this materialist point of view so what
does this look like on the right it
looks like the right is embracing its
traditions looks like the right is
wanting to make America great again
it's the right looking back first
through the Tea Party then through the
Trump movement and saying you know there
was something that we have lost even
amidst this material prosperity that we
want to regain we want to look back to
so so we look back to our ancestors we
look forward to the future what does
this look like on the left well it's the
left embracing their own culture and
it's the left embracing their own
religion and for the left their religion
is environmentalism their religion is
global warming their religion is the
green new deal that's why this crazy
plan that costs 93 trillion dollars that
would outlaw your home your car your
airplane your everything is base
secondly become the central discussion
during the 2020 Democrat primaries
that's what it's because it's a
harkening back beyond just mere economic
matters all the way to religious matters
which on the left means environmentalism
the clearest sign of this a clear a sign
of the rejection of the nineties of the
rejection of neoliberalism is that
Hillary is out I know there have been
how many times as she said I'm probably
not gonna run I know it doesn't look
like I'm gonna run some adviser leaks
and says she's not gonna run but it
wasn't her saying it herself
why because Hillary Clinton's been
running for president since she was six
years old but now she has come out and
said on my own hometown news network
news 12 because Hillary Clinton who is
my distant cousin I'm sorry to say it
also lives at the town over from where I
grew up basically ma'am there's are
really a lot going on in our little
neighborhood isn't there because in
Chappaqua you have Hillary Clinton
living then in Bedford Hills that's
where I grew up and then in Yorktown
Heights in the ritzy er part Northern
you have Alexandria Ocasio Cortez I
think I'm the only Republican in my
entire home County regardless that's a
diversion should that's a digression
rather she comes out on newsChannel 12
and she announces once and for all
Hillary Clinton is not running for
president in 2020 can you tell me now
standing here a hundred percent that
you've ruled it out I'm not running but
I'm gonna keep working and speaking and
standing up for what I believe so even
even there she says I'm not running it
it seems as though that's his ironclad
as it could possibly be however she's a
Clinton so she can't ever give a
straight answer on anything so she I am
NOT running if you have to parse that in
Clinton ease it she could run tomorrow
currently she's not running she could
run tomorrow but it does appear that
it's too late there are too many
competitors in the race already too many
people who will use up her donors it's a
little too late for her to jump in she
isn't doing the things that you need to
do to run and she's not running because
the Democrats don't want her and Hillary
Clinton is pretty empty she can be
whatever she wants she can be a
hard-line ideologue then she can
compromise on her ideology if she thinks
the ends just if
by the means she's a Clinton being a
Clinton means never have to say what you
really believe cuz you don't believe
anything Hillary Clinton from her days
at well Wellesley was clearly leaning
left she was she loved Saul Alinsky
rules for radicals she did have this
essential leftist belief and she let it
get quashed for decades and decades well
she supported her husband while she
supported the New Democrats and now the
Democrat Party has thrown her out for
that even if down in her core she's
really a hard-line leftist they're
throwing her out that they want somebody
who is fully committed to the cause
there was a poll that came out yesterday
the NBC Wall Street Journal poll it said
oh the thing that Democrat voters least
want in 2020 is a candidate who's a
socialist or who's over seventy five now
this was being aired as evidence that no
no the Democrats are gonna moderate no
no no Michael what are you talking about
the Democrats are gonna nominate a
centrist and they're gonna beat Trump
those headlines were all wrong because
what the headline showed is that in a
general election being a socialist and
being over 75 was not preferable but
that's not the case for the Democrats
and as we see time and time again what
the Democrats want is a far left winger
someone who is gonna react to Trump is
the polar opposite he's gonna be a
hardline socialist that that is a bad
incentive for Democrats because if the
Democrats only have incentives to
nominate some far left winger in their
primary they're gonna have a very hard
time in the general election that's
really what that NBC Wall Street Journal
poll shows and don't just take my word
for it Allison Camerata on CNN held a
focus group yesterday where she asked
what do people want in their candidate
do they want a Joe Biden who pretends to
be a regular man of the people Rust Belt
sort of guy or do they want some crazy
Bernie Sanders Alexandria occasional
cortex Elizabeth Warren whatever which
way are they gonna go the CNN panel was
pretty clear the the winning formula
would be for a Democrat to be pragmatic
and
centrist show of hands chew if you feel
that way how many of you feel that the
time is right for a progressive and
that's what would win girl we're ready
for progressive candidates they've won
all over the country and I think we need
bold strong leadership and you'll find
that in the progressives I think that we
had the standard bearer for the the kind
of pragmatic centrist candidate in
Hillary Clinton in 2016 and Donald Trump
is now president he is not your average
political candidate so we we really need
to try to think outside the box because
you know it seems like the dudes made a
rubber like anything you throw at him
just bounces off I mean there's nothing
that sticks absolute there's a lot of
insight in that panel there's a ton of
insight one that he's the Teflon Don
that they keep what are they throwing at
him they're throwing the Russia
accusations they're throwing campaign
finance accusations there's word
corruption accusatory all these things
at him they're saying he's too
conservative then they're saying he
doesn't have any political beliefs he's
nothing then they throwing all these
things at him and it just bounces off of
him and so what these progressives are
saying is that there is no way that
nominating an empty vessel is going to
beat that the way that you're gonna beat
the Teflon Don is you got to be so
direct you got a channel all of your
forces all of your ideology all of your
identity politics that's the only way
that they're gonna take him down what's
the practical consequence of this we'll
get to it in a second but first gotta
make a little more money with mint
mobile there are things in life that are
not right they're just not right carpet
in showers eating a dip with your
fingers chunky style milk none of those
things are you know what else isn't
right
paying too much for your phone bill that
is not right thanks to mint mobile you
do not have to overpay for your wireless
anymore with a mint mobile you can cut
your wireless bill down to just 15 bucks
a month
they've reimagined Wireless making it
easy and online-only which means that
they can pass the savings on to you you
can save over $1,000
a year with mint mobile without
sacrificing quality service it sounds
too good to be true it is not too good
to be true it's just that you are
getting gouged by big big phone by the
big cellular companies they're gouging
you like crazy stop pouring that money
down the drain you can cut your wireless
bill down to fifteen bucks a month
that's it one five use your own phone
with any mint mobile plan you can choose
plans between three eight and twelve
gigabytes of 4G LTE data what it is the
way the phone companies guide you is
they charge you for unlimited data that
you're not using that you will never use
stop getting ripped off if you're not a
hundred percent satisfied there's a
seven day money-back guarantee you can
get your new wireless plan for just
fifteen bucks a month get the plan
shipped to your door for free go to mint
mobile comm slash Knowles kayano wles
mint mobile comm slash Knowles can or
wles cut your wireless bill down to
fifteen bucks a month get free shipping
on your mobile plan mint mobile comm
slash Knowles Democrats want a
progressive they want a hardcore
progressive in 2020 what is the
practical consequence of that mr. vice
president former vice president joe
biden
unfortunately you ran in 1988 you ran in
2008 you never got the job looks like
you're probably not gonna get it again
how many of you would like to see Joe
Biden get in show of hands what's
happening time is done be honest I used
to think like you know because obviously
who's Ryan I kind of know Obama wave and
I thought he was the I thought he was a
person that would unite the party but to
be honest you know senator Biden really
comes from the kind of the good-old-boy
politics of the past
I don't think Joe Biden represents that
new thing that we need we just we need a
new economy we need a new politics and
meaning someone different new new new we
don't need guys who compromise we don't
need guys who were old there were two
ways to read that line by the first
gentleman who said Joe Biden represents
the good-old-boy politics of the past
the one way to read it is identity
politics he's an old white guy he looks
like the good old boys doesn't he and so
I think there's a little bit of that
going on obviously the Democrat Party is
quite concerned
with identity politics but I think
actually to give this guy the charitable
read of what he's saying and I and I
think a legitimate one when he's talking
about the good-old-boy politics I think
what he's talking about is compromise I
think what he's talking about is
speaking to the other side is not
treating the other side like they're a
bunch of Nazis because Joe Biden was
able to do this Joe Biden was this tough
a partisan as anybody there is - and
don't let anyone tell you otherwise
however during the period of time that
he was very prominent in the Senate was
basically talking from the 70s all the
way up until he was vice president
you're looking at a guy who at least had
the impression that he could work with
the other side you're looking at a guy
who was working in a political era that
rewarded to some degree compromise that
rewarded being moderate that rewarded
being able to work with other people
that is not our time in politics or time
in politics actually punishes you if you
were seem to be able to talk to the
other side or work with the other side
especially on the left as the left has
decided that the right-wingers are Nazis
I mean they call us Nazis all the time
they call us fascist Nazi criminal
terror all these sort of things and so
if you work with those people you're
part of the problem you're not part of
the solution and Joe Biden has
cultivated that image for his entire
career I think both of those things are
really working against him so what do
they care about you've got a little
taste of identity politics you got a
little bit of you want a little more
radicalism you want a little more
leftism but how does that manifest he's
being far left can mean anything it can
mean you want 90% tax rates
it can mean you want to you know have
the workers take over the means of
production it can have an economic focus
or kind of this environmental focus it
can have a sexual focus and be feminist
leftism
or can have an environmental focus I
keep coming back to that because that is
I think at the base of Democrats 2020
plans that I think is at the base of
what the left is looking at and the the
panel can explain the policies they're
looking to
the panel can explain the political
issues that they're looking toward and
then I'll explain why they've been duped
into thinking that's the primary policy
what will you be voting on in 2020 I
feel if the election were held today I'm
alright what's your big issue that you
feel you would vote on you know my big
issue truly is about climate change I
think because it it touches everyone and
it touches jobs and it touches our
future and we cannot have a conversation
about politics without considering what
we are doing to the planet but I mean
you see people freaking out over the
wall in these migrants coming up from
from Central and South America I mean
that's going to be like nothing compared
to the migration we will see as climate
change really starts to affect the sea
level rise I mean the ice is melting
fast the ice is melting fat just as a
side note that isn't true the actually
ice in the Antarctic ice in the North
Pole as well is there is more ice than
less ice the I it depends on the time of
the year obviously but overall the
amount of ice that we're seeing there is
greater then it was when Al Gore told us
the world was ending that's just a sight
dime that's just a slight factual point
but it actually doesn't really matter
what the facts are what matters for 2020
is what the Democrats think that the
facts are and what you hear is a
universalizing totalizing religious
system that is why it's the Andrew
Breitbart lesson applied to the left
Andrew Breitbart says politics is
downstream of culture we know from
Russell Kirk and from many other people
culture is downstream of religion it's
downstream of the cult it's what we
worship what we worship defines the
culture it's also been said many times
at all political problems ultimately our
theological problems and the left is
waking up to this and the previous
totalizing religion for the left was
communism during the 20th century it was
varying degrees of communism that was
the religion use here Bernie Sanders
still talk in this way vacationed in the
Soviet Union he had a fascination with
communism he would always defend
communists
dictators that was his religion it has
shifted now after the fall of the Soviet
Union after the fall of the Berlin Wall
there was no more communism to idolize
it had so obviously failed and so they
had to take that totalizing religion for
the left and transform it they've
transformed it into environmentalism
every political issue for the left can
boil down to that first principle even
illegal immigration they say oh you
think illegal immigration is bad now
just wait until the Sun monster melts
all the ice caps then it'll be really
bad oh you think that the energy
industry is difficult now you think gas
prices are high now just wait until
global warming destroys our economy
makes it such that we can't use fossil
fuels once we deplete all our fossil
fuels look at what price is just weight
and global warming global warming global
warming because it gives people a sense
of purpose it gives them a substitute
for sin it gives them a substitute for
redemption it gives them a substitute
for penance it gives them a substitute
for salvation for saving the world gives
them a substitute for charity it's gonna
affect everybody on earth that is what
it's all boiling down to that's why the
green New Deal is an all-encompassing
economic plan political plants social
plan that's why it's gaining traction
because it's a lunatic plan we've all
read the draft legislation I think I
read it on the show so how can people
get behind it because it touches
everything totally changes everything we
have a beautiful new world ahead of us a
utopia ahead of us all based on this
foundational myth which is global
warming this is the global struggle this
is the war you heard Alexandria Cassio
Cortez say we need to gear up for
climate change and mobilize for climate
change the way we mobilized for World
War two and what's so ironic about that
is she then say in the same breath she
says and we should stop mobilizing for
Wars so we need to treatment global
warming like it's a war but we shouldn't
fight any wars we shouldn't find the
actual Wars it's a total inversion
Alexander Akasha Cortez said this on
Twitter yesterday
she was trying to defend Ilan Omar Elano
Mara doesn't like the Jews and she hates
the Jewish state and Ben has talked
about it on his show she's she is
anti-semitic I don't throw that word
around lightly I try not to use those
sort of words but she is exhibiting that
and so the left is trying to defend her
AOC is trying to defend her specifically
and so she's she tweets that quote I
remember a time when it was unacceptable
to question the Iraq war all of Congress
was wrong including both the GOP and
Democrat Party and led my generation
into a disastrous and long war that
virtually all would come to regret
except for the one member who stood up
barbara Lee okay now she then responded
to this and she said oh wait a minute
I'm sorry I meant Afghanistan war my
apologies sir she said because there
were we debated the Iraq war
I remember the debates over the Iraq war
but Alexandria Ocasio Cortes doesn't
because she's got the memory and
historical knowledge of a fruit fly
so she said oh no I'm sorry I made a
completely different war this would be a
gaffe that would really matter if a
Republican said it with her they ignore
it and then she doubles down she says
quote but honestly we shouldn't have
been in either war and we should end the
authorization of military force while
we're at it so this is you know she's
that person who can't apologize she's
that person who gets something wrong and
then she sort of apologizes because she
has to and then she tries to tell you
why she was actually right in the first
place she's doing that thing which is
just evidence of someone without any
humility but look at the radicalism of
that statement because if she came out
and said I'm against the Iraq war okay a
lot of people are against the Iraq war
dumb Trump in many ways is against the
Iraq war so okay that's fine they're
plenty of criticisms to hurl at the Iraq
war but she's criticizing any military
response after 9/11 she's criticizing
the Afghanistan war she's criticizing
the authorization for the use of
military force after 9/11 after Islamic
terrorists who were harbored by
nation-states
took down our center of commerce the
World Trade Center killed 3,000 American
civilians attacked our Pentagon and
tried to attack either the White House
or the Capitol and because of the
heroism of people on flight 93 were
taken down before they could succeed we
are talking about the most significant
terrorist attack on our nation ever and
she says no we shouldn't have responded
no no we shouldn't respond
there is nothing noble about this there
is nothing right about this this is
moral idiocy this is like people who
read the line turn the other cheek and
twist that and pervert that line into a
sick pacifism that would let the cruel
rape the earth rather than reading it as
it is which is a spiritual tactic and
strategy for humility to defeat the
Prince of pride this is a perverted
pacifism but I I bring it up in this
case not just to criticize what she said
on its merits though I will do that but
to show the perversity of the green New
Deal she says we need to mobilize for
war to attack plastic litter and air
pollution but we shouldn't mobilize for
war when people declare war on us and
kill 3,000 of our civilians look at the
backwardness of that look at the total
inversion of that this is by the way why
the green new deal i think is just
fatally flawed as a matter of public
policy
cocaine Mitch seems to think the same
thing which is why he won't he really
wants to bring it up for a vote said we
need to get everyone on the record here
you know that there is a sense that we
have Liberty Liberty is good to protect
we like protecting our Liberty our
traditional liberties as their embodied
in institutions and our traditional
rights as Americans we want to protect
those liberties
however the protection of life has to
come first you don't have liberties
without life protection when they come
into conflict you do for a spell have to
prioritize protection and what these
Democrats are doing is they're totally
flipping it they're saying that they're
threatening
both security and liberty they're
threatening our liberty through the
green New Deal they're saying we're
gonna take away all your money your
house your car your rights your
political representation we're going to
basically undo the American Republican
system and we're going to outsource all
political decisions to a little
committee of Democrats but they're also
threatening our security because at the
same time they're saying we're gonna
mobilize for the the some monster we're
not gonna fight any Wars it's a big
loser I think in 2020 but they've bought
into this because of their religious
fervor we'll see by the way how Liz
Warren is imperiling her 20/20 hopes
will also talk about auto sexuality
screwing yourself has never been so
politically correct and then we'll get
to Lent if we have time for Mardi Gras
but first go to daily wire comm you know
what you get you get everything ten
bucks a month hundred dollars for an
annual membership you get everything you
can't ask questions in the mail bag
that's coming up on Thursday we're not
gonna have a show tomorrow because I'm
gonna be guest hosting the Fox program
outnumbered so tune in to that that's at
noon Eastern 9 a.m. Pacific tell your
friends that'll be a lot of fun it'll be
me and four women
what could be better but we are gonna
have a show on Thursday so get your mail
by questions and we're gonna show on
Friday daily wire calm you get the
leftist here's tumblr it is you're not
going to see the ice caps melt
that's probably unlikely but you will
see the snowflakes melt and you will be
able to fill your tumblers with the
delish delicious liquid so go to daily
wire.com we'll be right back with a lot
more
Elizabeth Warren Elizabeth Warren is
still failing to answer the only
question that matters to her campaign
her fraud or lying about her heritage
her original lie that has permitted her
entire career and she keeps getting this
answer wrong so now she's doing an
interview on CNN friendly outlet with
David Axelrod a Democrat operative
obviously a friendly person and he says
how were you gonna answer this and she
still hasn't come up with an answer
obviously that's a very small part of of
your of your lineage you know 1/32 or
something so why why did you do it so
like I said I grew up in Oklahoma I
learned about my family the same way
most people learn about their families
you know from my mom and my dad and my
aunt's and my uncles she's answering
these questions like she's a perp on To
Catch a Predator
she's anzo so why don't you take a seat
right over there okay okay yeah so what
were you doing here today huh what were
you it's like David Axelrod's become
Chris Hanson so what would you plan to
do here oh nothing nothing I was just uh
I was just learning about my family like
most people do about you know from their
father mother and father and uh she's
trying to play it down she's trying to
oh no it's nothing no no it's it's not
nothing it's something this is the
biggest threat to your political career
you've got to deal with it like an adult
you've got you can't pretend that's not
real you got to deal with it head-on
she should attack it head-on she keeps
playing defense but but the issue is all
of the fraud this is a big deal she
claimed to the Texas Bar Association
that she was Native American she claimed
to Harvard University she was Native
American this helps you get jobs this
helps you in hiring Harvard bragged
about it this gives you a tremendous
professional advantage she has to come
out she I'm gonna get if she watches the
show senator Warren
Trix Warren uh lot chief Lyle wathah I
will give you the answer for your
campaign to at least have a shot at
working through this but what does she
do
she keeps denying deny deny deny deny
she never helped her in her whole
professional career based on what I'd
learned growing up and the fact that I
love my family
decades ago I sometimes identified as
Native American it's it's there it never
had anything to do with any job that I
ever got that's been fully documented
the university is kind of fudged and
used you for their own purpose never had
it never had anything to do with my
getting a job it it even so I shouldn't
have done it
I'm not a person of color uh I am NOT a
citizen of a tribe but what I try to do
is be a good friend to Native Americans
that's her defense that's her defense I
love my family and I try to be a good
friend and then she says it didn't help
her get a job it did help her get a job
it did of course it did that's why she
did it if she wants to win if she wants
to get past this she has to just take a
little tiny dose of humility just try to
get rid of that just a little in the
[ __ ] of the armor of pride just knock
away a little bit she has to stop
thinking in such a self-centered way but
she can't do it she needs to stop
defending the cheating to get a job she
has to stop denying that the cheating
got her a job she needs to speak in
cultural terms she's not learning the
lesson that younger Democrats have
learned what she needs to go out there
and say I thought I was more Native
American than I am when I was a kid
because of what my family told me I
thought I was more Native American than
I am and I identified myself as more
Native American than I am because I
learned about the historical struggles
the Native Americans went through and I
really this resonated with me
and I felt that it was a part of my
family and I didn't want to abandon that
part of my family and I didn't want it
to just disappear
I didn't want it to be watered down she
can even use the intersectionality
language you can say I didn't want it to
be have all of the whiteness overshadow
this real ancestor that I thought that I
had that I thought I had in my
relatively recent history I didn't want
it to disappear and I know now that that
was wrong I know that it was the wrong
view of racial politics but it's what I
did I did it for the best of intentions
I did it because of a real natural sense
of identity with an ancestor and a
people that have been really hurt and it
was wrong and it was the sort of thing
that immature people do and I'm sorry
that I did it but I've matured I've
stopped doing it I obviously I did it
for the best of intentions but the road
to hell is paved with good intentions
and and and I I am where I am and that's
who I am and that's and I'm sorry if it
helped me get a job I'm sorry for that I
just didn't think through it was wrong
to do and I did it because of a real
sense of heritage that maybe was just in
my head maybe was just in the family
folklore and I'm sorry for that if she
came out and said that she might be able
to sweep past this because it would be a
total apology it would be not a denial
it would be not a it's not a big deal it
would be nada I love my family and I'm a
good friend it would be none of that it
would actually be getting to the heart
of it because there is I get it well
I've done genealogical research two
people have a sense of belonging a sense
of their place in politics and history
because of their family because of their
heritage because of their family
traditions this is an area where I
actually see the logic of identity
politics or I at least see the premise
of I don't I don't see the logic because
the logic just falls apart as the left
implements identity politics but I tote
I totally get it
my family came over on the Mayflower
four members of my family came over on
the Mayflower one of them died from
wounds incurred at
curr hill during the Revolutionary War
another one went on to serve of George
Washington throughout the entire Valley
Forge throughout the Revolutionary War I
had another family member die at the
Second Battle of Bull Run in the Civil
War I've had ancestors in most American
wars that gives me a sense of America
and a sense of pride in America and a
sense of ownership and belonging and a
responsibility and an accountability to
our tradition and I completely
understand if your ancestors were slaves
that you would have a very different
view of America I totally get that and
you might have a little resentment
toward America totally get that too now
the answer the way to work out of this
is that if you allow that resentment to
just Fester with pride with entitlement
with a chip on your shoulder with a
grudge with hatred then it becomes the
identity politics that the left has
today but if you look at that and you
see history for what it is and then you
have some humility and some grace and
some forgiveness and some gratitude for
all the wonderful things that this
country is done and you have some pride
in helping even if your ancestors were
brought here and changed that they
helped to build this country that is so
wonderful that you today can be a
senator or you can run for this or you
can have a job or you can have all the
freedoms and all of the prosperity in
the world that's that's a way to work
out of that I heritage does matter
it totally does that's why people are
rightly angry at Liz Warren that's why
Liz Warren cynically pretended to be a
Native American and if she can speak in
those terms I think it would resonate
with her voters they would resonate with
Republicans I think it would allow her
to work out of this a little bit but it
would require a little dose of humility
a little bit of introspection and a
little bit of grace for the country and
and the Democrat Party in 2019 has none
of that none of that this is the the
wonderful aspect of 2019 2020 for
Democrats is you
shows the logical conclusions of their
ideas we are now talking because the
Democrats have become radicalized
because they don't want to moderate they
don't want to centrist they they want a
far leftist they are showing the logical
conclusions of their ideas the logical
conclusion of identity politics the
whitest woman on earth is an Indian the
logical conclusion of abortion we should
kill babies after they've been born the
logical conclusion of global warming we
should overthrow the Republic we should
tax everyone at 80% we should suspend
all of our political liberties if if
truly the entire world is going to end
in 12 years because of the Sun monster
as aoc says of course yeah of course we
should do everything we can including
suspending political liberties including
totally revolutionising overthrowing the
Republic is everything we possibly can
to stop that now of course it isn't true
the world isn't going to end in 12 years
I'll bet
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes every penny
that I have to my name that the world
will not end in 12 years as she says it
does
AOC congresswoman if you're watching I
know you watch the show I am willing to
bet every single penny I have to my name
that the world will not end in 12 years
if you're willing to take the other side
of that bet now this is a great bet
because if she's right by the way you
know I want to exactly have to pay out
but every penny to my name if you if you
will take it but of course they don't
really believe that I'm gonna be talking
about this by the way I'm gonna be
giving a speech in Cincinnati on
Thursday about how the global warming
alarmists don't really believe what they
say that they believe but that'll be a
topic for another day that this is and
the logical conclusion by the way this
is my favorite story we have to get to
it before the end today the logical
conclusion of the sexual revolution
which is so much of what the left talks
about gender sexuality sexual preference
the logical conclusion of the sexual
revolution is something called Auto
sexuality otter a sexuality this is
there was a big headline in the
newspapers yesterday and today it gives
new meaning to the phrase go screw
yourself
the piece and Metro yesterday said quote
what it's like being Auto sexual when
you find yourself attracted to yourself
Auto this is the logical conclusion of
the sexual revolution is screwing
yourself that's it this the piece opens
up it says quote sexuality is fluid as
with lots of things it can involve and
Boomerang over time though so often
thought about in binary terms just as
with gender there are many different
sexualities people identify as Auto
sexuality is one such identification
that is seldom talked about it's the
idea of being sexually attracted to
yourself and can also come with being
Auto romantic experiencing the
relationship with yourself as romantic
the piece goes on it can mean being
turned on by your own look and nudity
getting butterflies when you think about
yourself being excited to spend time
alone and cover your ears parents who
are watching with children
and masturbating to the idea of yourself
it's all the feelings we get for a
potential new suitor but for ourselves
Agia Vitale is Auto sexual and Auto
romantic she is also engaged to get
married to herself after proposing in
March 2017 after becoming aware of her
sexuality at the age of seven she didn't
explore her feelings until she was in
college that's because she's not a boy a
boy said I don't want to get too graphic
here actually
Woody Allen defendant as he explained
this point very clearly in Annie Hall
masturbation at sex with someone I love
this drug is gia Vitale it took her
longer to come to Woody Allen's
conclusion this is the logical
consequence of the left's sexual
revolution the sexual revolution is all
around us and by the way I'm you know
I'm speaking not as this totally removed
Kermit from this culture art you know
during my atheistic more decadent
college days my single days I aspired to
be a brigadier general in the sexual
revolution it doesn't just affect
the left this affects the left the
center and the right and what they try
to do is they try to make the right out
as these prudish people who have no idea
what they're talking about oh they just
don't know they just can't imagine
sexuality just they're they're so
sheltered no not at all not at all first
of all if you're in the modern culture
you are in the sexual revolution and
unless you really are stick firmly to
conservative principles or to really
firmly to certain religious principles
this is how you behave the hook-up
culture is all around us the swipe right
or swipe left culture is all around us
but ultimately having seen many
Vantage's of this it is ultimately just
about selfishness that's all the sexual
revolution ever meant and we're we're
seeing it at the very end with Auto
sexuality but it's all it meant this is
why now the left looks on traditional
sexual morality and they just they don't
get it why on earth would anyone ever
care what sort of things you're doing
the bedroom why on earth would anyone
care what you do with yourself as Woody
Allen meant the auto sexuals seemed to
do why would anyone care this shows why
traditional morality holds a program for
inventive sexuality or kinky myths or
whatever because all of those things or
all of them to varying degrees turn the
focus of sexuality onto the self and
we're in a we're in a time where this is
just the fact that is just the fact of
our culture is that sexuality has been
turned totally to the self we have sex
robots that are hearing reported on
every single day sex robot brothels
virtual reality porn and in cultures
where these have been really introduced
to a larger degree I'm thinking mostly
of Japan birth rates drop sex with women
drops there was one study that showed
that young Japanese men would prefer
auto sexuality than to have sex with a
woman what this does to the logical
consequence of this is it makes sex
unsexy that's all at
it turns out that all of human history
from the dawn of time until I don't know
1962 may have been a little bit wiser
than we are today and look a bit between
the campus kangaroo courts between this
clinical treatment of sex where you
basically need to get a contract looked
over by a notary public before you can
kiss a girl what it what it is done is
the impossible the left has succeeded at
the impossible they've made sex boring
this is I guess this is a good topic to
end on now on Mardi Gras it's Fat
Tuesday again speaking of our sexual
revolution you are so so lucky that
nobody in this room has beads right now
we'd be getting quite a quite the sexual
revolution show this is Mardi Gras this
is Fat Tuesday this is when Christians
gorged themselves and do decadent things
then it leads into the penitential
period of Lent begins on Ash Wednesday
and it ends on Easter this is a time of
penitence this is a time of abstention
from certain things this is a time of
fasting people look on Christians as
weird
when they do this when they fast for a
couple days it's because we're in a
culture that is all about instant
gratification
it's all about gratifying the flesh but
ultimately that becomes boring you know
the idea I think was Archbishop Fulton
sheen said that the traditional Catholic
or Eastern Orthodox or traditional
Christian idea of fasting is first you
have the fast then you have the feast
and that the modern idea has become
first you have the feast then you have
the hangover that's the our culture
first you have the feast and then you
have the anger people get sex often
people gorge themselves people are just
when you give in to the appetites of the
flesh all the time they lose their
sensation they stop being nice they lead
you ultimately to board to a sort of
depression - you need constantly more
and more eventually there's not more and
more to stimulate you maybe the old idea
maybe the tradition was a little wiser
so now
we have a feast then we're gonna have a
fast for 40 days and then we're gonna
have another feast and I look forward to
all of it I look forward to seeing all
of you well I'll see you tomorrow on Fox
if you tune in at 9:00 a.m. Pacific 12
p.m. noon on outnumbered it'll be me and
a bunch of lovely ladies and then I'll
see you on Thursday both for the show
and for my speech in Cincinnati in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Hall show
[Music]
the michael dole's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy more senior producer Jonathan hey
our supervising producer is Mathis
clever and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jessa
all Vera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19